[Musik]
sirenen gegen das vergessen ganz israel
hält inne heute wieder holocaust
gedenken sechs millionen juden ermordet
durch das mörderische system der nazis
das vor genau 80 jahren seinen anfang
nahm mit der aktion reinhardt dem beginn
des systematischen morgens auf dessen
spuren hat sich unser reporter hannes
radigk begeben
in belgien sobibor und treblinka waren
die ersten deutschen vernichtungslager
hier wurde die systematischer
industrialisierte und arbeitsteilige
ermordung der europäischen juden erst
erprobt und dann mit aller grausamkeit
perfektioniert doch im allgemeinen
gedächtnis an den holocaust spielen
diese drei orte wenn überhaupt nur eine
nebenrolle
ich möchte herausfinden warum das so ist
warum besuchen jährlich über zwei
millionen menschen die kz gedenkstätte
auschwitz birkenau aber nur wenige
zehntausend belgien sobibor und
treblinka
um antworten zu finden mache ich mich
auf den weg zu den drei orten wo der
größte massenmord der menschheit seinen
anfang nahm der
nationalsozialistischen rassenwahn sah
vor dass alle juden in den von
deutschland besetzten gebieten
vernichtet werden sollten auch polen war
damals besetzt
im touro college in berlin treffe ich
professor stefan dienstes er ist
historiker und holocaust forscher drei
lager der aktion reinhardt also welcher
sobibor und treblinka sind die ersten
vernichtungslager die gebaut werden sie
sind erprobungs orte man experimentiert
dort mit dem industriellen massenmord
also der wird nicht in auschwitz
erfunden und mit
1,8 millionen toten ist das auch nicht
nochmals größere dimension als ein
ausschnitt anders als in auschwitz gibt
es in den lagern der aktion reinhardt
keine selektion das sind einfach keine
arbeitslager ist in rheine dort lagert
die leute haben keinen anderen nutzen er
der reinkommt wird ermordet und deswegen
haben wir auch am ende nur 150
überlebende aus gießen lagern hier in
bälde im dünn besiedelten osten des
landes entstand das erste
vernichtungslager der so genannten
aktionen reinhaut
mit dem märz 1942 kam der erste zug mit
juden aus dem ghetto lublin hier an das
lager war nur etwa 265 x 275 meter groß
und hatte einen eigenen gleisanschluss
vom bahnsteig gab es für die juden nur
noch einen weg ein bisschen betonwände
symbolisieren den sogenannten schlauch
das war der weg den die juden land
getrieben worden aus den eisenbahnwagen
hin zu den gaskammern
insgesamt wurden hier etwa 600.000
menschen vergast die leichen wurden erst
in massengräbern verscharrt und später
unter freiem himmel verbrannt am 11
dezember 1942 traf der letzte transport
mit juden in welcher zeit lange vor
kriegsende hat die ss das
vernichtungslager belzec dem erdboden
gleichgemacht die spuren des massenmords
sollten beseitigt werden erst 2004 wurde
dann hier an ort und stelle das museum
und die gedenkstätte eröffnet
[Musik]
deshalb ist das muss ich um ein
wichtiger ort für die erinnerung an die
opfer und die holocaust forschung
leider wissen wir über diese orte sehr
wenig sie sind nicht im öffentlichen
gedächtnis und das liegt eben daran dass
es keine spuren gibt dass es keine
überlebenden mehr gibt sie sind
inzwischen alle tot und das ist
natürlich auch ein problem weil die
täter nur völlig unzureichend und auch
nur teilweise verurteilt wurden und umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir heute an diese
orte auch erinnern und sie nicht
vergessen gerade weil es nichts
sichtbares gibt
und genau deswegen ist unser bild
reporter hans rat geben dort hingereist
und jetzt zurück von dieser reise grüße
dich herzlich handels an die reise der
ja fast vergessenen lager dort ein
winziges lager das wäre gerade gesehen
haben einige hundert meter x 100-meter
hast du gesagt wo dann hunderttausende
ganz schnell vergast wurden deswegen war
diese reise für dich so wichtig genau
das ist wirklich es ist eine größe von
etwa zehn fußballfeldern in einem
winzigen kleinen dorf einer heutigen
ukrainischen grenze im damals besetzten
polen was da als erstes lager eben
errichtet worden ist als erstes reines
vernichtungslager
und es ist heute so wichtig dass diese
drei orte der aktion reinhardt nicht in
vergessenheit geraten weil hier der kern
des holocaust seinen ursprung hat und
weil die ss eben nach beendigung ihrer
mörderischen arbeit nachdem fast alle
polnischen juden vernichtet waren diese
lager 43 dem erdboden gleich gemacht
haben und alle spuren vernichtet haben
die beraten waren aus holz die wurden
abgebaut nur die gaskammern waren
gemauert auch die mauersteine wurden
anderweitig genutzt es wurden wäldern
gepflanzt und es wurden dort bauernhöfe
etabliert es war also
wunsch der ss dass wir vergessen was an
diesen orten passiert ist und das dürfen
wir nicht zulassen und zu guter letzt
müssen wir natürlich an die 1,8
millionen ermordeten gedenken und ihre
ehre aufrechterhalten täter waren
deutsche was tut deutschland dagegen
dass dieser ort in vergessenheit geraten
meine meinung nach viel zu wenig täter
waren deutsche wie du sagst und in
berlin an öffentlichen plätzen hängen
diese tafeln orte des schreckens die wir
nicht vergessen dürfen da ist von den
drei orten der aktion reinhardt nur
treblinka
verschriftlicht worden sobibor in
belgien finden nicht statt und das waren
die beiden ersten vernichtungslager dies
gab und da haben die nazis eben diese
erprobungen gemacht um dann eben mit
diesen barbarischen wissen spätere
konzentrationslager im am laufenden zu
haben und eben diese systematik
überhaupt zu verstehen und durchführen
zu können und das ist eben unsere
pflicht unsere deutsche pflicht nicht
auf anfragen aus polen zu warten ob wir
vielleicht da unterstützen dürfe sondern
einfach ohne wenn und aber zusagen
bestehen zu unserer geschichte wir
stehen zu den verbrechen die im
deutschen namen und von deutschen verübt
worden sind auf polnischem auf damals
eben heute polnischen boden aber eben
damals im von deutschen besetzten polen
und deshalb überweisen wir eine summe
iks um diese gedenkstätten am laufen zu
halten polen finanziert das heute aus
töpfen des kulturministeriums das sind
ungefähr 2,6 millionen euro jedes jahr
für diese drei gedenkstätten und da
denke ich wäre deutschland gut beraten
wenn sie da zumindest ein teil davon
ohne wenn und aber und ohne auf anträge
zur warten ein tag beweisen würde das
ist sicherlich unsere verantwortung
hannes rafik vielen herzlichen dank für
diese eindrücklichen berichte die die
uns mitgebracht danke dir an diesem tag
an dem also wieder die sirenen geheult
haben in israel an dem für mindestens
einen moment das ganze leben dort
stillstand